we're told the following tables give all
of the input output pairs for the
functions
s and t so we see this first table here
we have some
x's and then they tell us what the
corresponding s of x is
and then in this table that we have some
x's and they tell us the corresponding
t of x it says complete the table for
the composite function
s of t of x we want to fill in these
five entries here and then they ask us
are s and t
inverses so pause this video and see if
you can figure this out on your own
before we work through it together
all right now let's work through this
together so let's just remind ourselves
what's going on with the composite
function like this
so you're going to take some x value and
it looks like we're first going to put
it
into the function t that is
going to output t of x
and then we're going to take that output
take that t of x and then it will be the
input
into s so then we're going to input that
into
s and then that would output s of
what we inputted which in this case is t
of x
so let's go on that journey so what
we're going to do is first take these
numbers
put them into the function t
figure out what it outputs and then take
that output and then put it into the
function s
it's going to be a fun little ride all
right so when x
is equal to 12 we're going to put it
into our function t
first so when x is an input into t
the output is equal to negative one so
that's our t of x
and then we're gonna take this negative
one and input it into s
so negative one here and when you input
that into
s you get as the output s of negative 1
is 12. so s of t of x is 12.
so interestingly this is 12.
now let's do the next one so when we
input
18 into t so the 18 is the input
it t of x t of 18 is 2 and then if we
want to do if we want to input that
into s so this is going to be the input
into s
the output is 18 very
interesting all right let's keep going
so when we input 61 into t
the output is 8 then when we take eight
and we
input it into s of x or s of eight i
should say it's going to be 61.
all right things are things are looking
good so far
and i'm running out of colors i'll do
green so when we take 70 and we input it
into t t of 70 is
7 when you take 7 and
input it into s you get 70.
all right and then one last one i will
do
in this blue color when you take a
hundred
input it into t it outputs negative five
you take negative five input into s you
get
one 100 so in every situation
that we have looked at right over here
in all of these
situations we see that s
of t of x
is equal to x which inclines us to
believe that they are inverses remember
if these two are inverses of each other
this would be true
and also t of s of x
is going to be equal to x but we don't
really know
100 unless we know that we have looked
at every combination in
the domains for each of them now when
you look at these
two tables up here and i could have done
this this is the one we looked at on our
journey to get to this 12 right over
here
following table gives all of the input
output pairs for the function
s and t so this right over here is the
domain
for the function s and this right over
here is the domain
for the function t so because for every
member of
the function s every member of the
domain of the function s
the corresponding output right over
there
is the domain for the function t
and it takes us back to where we began
and then the opposite is true as well
for every member of the domain of t
what it outputs that is the all of the
possible inputs for x and they all take
us back to where we began
so yes the functions are inverses